okay for people who are joining this
livestream this is yet another episode
in our effort to get our database
integration functionality ready for
release with version 1204 language and
there were a number of contentious
issues that we had run into um and we
need to continue grinding on them so I
think that one of the main issues was
the handling of entity versus entity
class and the formatting of what happens
there so what where we got in the
previous some discussion
so I think we got to the point where we
decided that most of that all of the new
and c-class like heads should not format
that single entity should format but
they should have something that
indicates when they are more complex
than having just a simple string as the
first argument and Bible sure we didn't
we didn't seem to take notes here but I
mean the main then that I think we need
to notate here okay um oh wait a minute
I seems like rogered just yet okay so
welcome desktop latest version is
crashing on on lambda okay I'm using
Mathematica instead but please check the
laptops you can come and get the other
one okay okay thanks yep okay um okay so
what we had talked about last time was
things where there is a okay so the case
so this is about formatting and it's
about formatting of entities so the
conclusion of its of its entity if there
is a a common name use that in the
formatting that makes sense to people
those what we concluded last time is
that correct yes okay um annotate with
icons
to indicate other um other stuff you
know these other these other operations
okay now with entity class
okay so what on this input right I'm a
little disappointed we don't have a
summary that somebody else made do I
need to make the summary are you guys on
top of this do you know what to do
Tony can you speak to that please mid
summary well of what we're supposed to
be doing here right so this case yes so
if if it's a named entity class and
format it otherwise it's code and don't
form it
yes that's basically right and but in
this case right we need to make sure
that for the input form for the input
here that we preserve I'm sorry
this this is an implicit entity so it
core syndicate re gory upstair so it's
still formats and that's fine but what
I'm saying is it's important to get the
original linguistics in it you get what
I'm saying
did you understand until the first
evaluation what said until the first
evaluations that is correct and I
believe that this output should probably
be open by default okay did you
understand what I'm saying yeah do we
disagree do we have any disagreement on
that
because these are single and I'm trying
to make sure you have a conclusion here
that we can go from it might a little
bit depends on the circumstances
obviously if you come from a contour
equal having an ordinance definitely
much nicer if you have a list of twenty
thousand of them and you evaluate their
movie demand form up
I mean I wonder whether in that case hey
I don't know I mean if this twenty
thousand of them the thing will elide
was short anyway I think it's not useful
to have them not open because I think
you just can't see what the heck is
going on without seeing without having
them open I mean the alternative would
be some interface element that open
encloses all of them on the screen of
all of them one by one
yes yes that's an interesting idea that
is an interesting idea I mean that
that's a general idea about elision of
stuff and in the yeah Carl on our live
stream asks the interesting question of
whether there's any hope for
multilingual entity names and the answer
is yes because we have translations of
WolframAlpha under but that's actually
something we haven't thought about him
and we presumably have that we
presumably have the information for like
Japanese for some of these things right
well sometimes yes but not I mean is it
worth us considering having a you know a
dollar entity language that switches
that I don't know interesting question
um we should add that to the list it's a
good idea okay Kimmy general comment
yeah I really don't like the fact that
the orange boxes of both entity and
c-class look exactly the same talking
about the border
okay I don't disagree with you I think
it's a source of confusion yeah okay do
we have Billy on the phone yes um I
agree with that statement
okay I think we should do something
different for entity classes what could
we do what is the the sign of class and
I don't mean I don't mean higher or
lower social class I mean I'm sorry I'm
making a joke they I mean what what is
that what is the sign that something is
a class we've tended to have those
multiple dots right I wonder if putting
dots around the border would be an
interesting way to indicate that it's a
class somehow
comments from anybody just another color
would be probably more
I think it's incomprehensible you need
something that has some semantic content
otherwise it's hopeless people can't
remember colors yeah but they always
distinguish that something is entity and
something is anything no they won't they
won't they'll just be confused they they
need something which has some semantic
connection with some some way that we're
indicating classes for some other reason
like the multiple dots for instance
Billy do you want to comment on this one
do you think would be what we discussed
last time that Tony trust fix this
morning the differentiation between
singular and plural in the entity type
that's something I don't think it's
enough Billy can you respond please can
you try a version of this which has this
kind of like dashed or dotted or
something around the edge yeah um but I
think it's a good idea to distinguish
them okay so for entity class under
what's okay so there's case one is named
entity class get yellow boxed right yes
okay what other what other entity
classes get yellow boxed my vote is for
no other but you were much against that
I I don't like the implicit one once I
mean I think I can I can live with the
OL and the class country all being
yellow boxed okay but so - okay hold on
guys that we're trying to make a list
right the the statement we don't want
any of them and then we say well but
some of them we do we need to you know
clarify hey background noise
um okay so this case here right
you're suggesting that becomes the
yellow box yes well it's ended
Plus and all could be considered as a
special name so it for it can be thought
of as falling in the category of named
class all right fine fine okay so so
those those two would get yellow boxed
and otherwise it wouldn't yellow box yes
okay I think I'm okay with that
now let's talk about we we had gotten
into the morass of aggregation functions
I know we have to talk about that um
okay what's this label business
what's that and how does that relate to
any of this
I feel like this meeting is not well
prepared okay can somebody please tell
me what is it we're supposed to be
talking about here okay so there is okay
labels are the same thing as common name
and when common name is not available we
fall back to canonical name right okay
so the hierarchy is labeling is a common
name followed by what is it called is it
called entity label what's it called in
an entity store Tony
the property is called label okay okay
so yes common name chests retreats the
label in an entrance door yes right I
understand but in the end the
knowledge-based common name is something
different
do you understand what I'm saying yes in
some case okay so let's talk about
something else does common name for an
entity from an external database
presumably common name would also
retrieve the function common name would
retrieve the label correct yes if
present yes if that is that documented
no it is not okay but in most cases will
not be present well unless you put it in
there right unless you put it in yes but
but we your this way we would be
introducing like some kind of reserved
name for that meaning that if the
database originally has something called
label that means I don't know something
no we're not doing that that's a
completely different level in the entity
store no it's not it leaves at the same
level as the properties what I'm saying
is that if you have something like a
mistake music record mistake that's
that's a mistake it it doesn't live Tony
that's wrong right it does not live at
the same level as the properties does it
it is some property a special tank
that's a mistake then we should have a
separate thing called something like you
know in entity store we should have a
separate thing called metadata or
something just like we have properties
we should have something called metadata
which means it's a thing that isn't you
know confused with the properties
because we don't want to have a reserved
name one way around this would be the
only label when it's a symbol not a
string but act like that and that way
there could be no collusion with no no
that's not gonna work there's no there's
no there's no symbol label that means
something completely different okay so
is it
case that these things possible in trees
in the data Association for given type a
label for the type okay possible
entities entries for each entity class
okay so is it the case that in the
database mapping that these are combined
with the actual names of columns in the
database true or not true
actually come not actually combined so
the current status is that the entity
framework tries to retrieve the label
for labeling all kind of objects if it's
available except for databases where
this has been disabled
okay that's a hack okay so let's go
through this again
okay the thing comes back from the
database it has a column name here and
has a value right for each for each um
row corresponding to an entity it has
something like this correct that's
correct
thank you okay so if we wanted to have a
label for formatting right the place
that in our existing framework in our in
memory framework what we would do is
have a property here called label that
says um you know write something like
that correct
so is that correct okay so that of
course is a hack relative to because it
means you're mixing that name with the
name of the columns correct correct
okay so what we need to do is obviously
separate it out
right and I don't know exactly how to do
it um you know possibly I don't know if
we've got some option name some symbol
option name that we can use in this
association we could use that symbol
option name and have a sub association
that gives the metadata well it actually
since this association I think has a no
because this is an association of
properties there is another problem as
well what if we decide that this label
is a function computed on the row how
are you going to express that
okay well maybe what we need to do is
some I mean Jerry should be a function
because you can use multiple columns to
remind the name
um and in fact we have a way to do that
because we are able to register
properties which are essentially
computed properties so the only real
problem here is that we don't want it to
be string so we can maybe Kerala suggest
that the symbol or some symbolic wrapper
why not sorry for what for the label
have it have it be a special computed
property
which has an on string name
um this way it will never collide with
names we're getting from the database
comps sorry sorry sorry I'm sorry you're
saying this should have an on string
name that's exactly what I was just
saying okay right - what I'm saying is
something different I'm saying we want a
sub Association so we can put multiple
things in there right it doesn't need to
be a sub Association it could just be an
tied label goes to blah and that yeah
people can be a symbol in a way we can
argue that sub Association will be wrong
what sub Association would be wrong we
can argue because essentially a label is
also a property maybe a computed
property now I'm suggesting a different
thing okay so look one possibility is we
just got to make up symbol names for
everything that we want to have in here
right so for example you know the most
natural thing
I wonder I wonder
you
see what we really want is a labeling
function which we already have where
does work what uses a labeling function
here
right either this or another option if
you plan for several such things would
be to have a single symbol and then the
thing you want will be a string inside
of course oh not well I wasn't thinking
inside but we could do that we could do
that we could say um you know we could
have a thing called you know I really
like this but something like entity
metadata of label zero whatever exactly
okay I think both of those are
reasonable things to go for the labeling
function that would be an option - ah
that will be a higher-level option an
entity store basically Tony does that
make sense to you
why does it have to be a function as
opposed to an explicit list well because
if you might want to function you might
not want a list yes but still in a
function on which level what we were
discussing was that the label can be on
the level of every row and if you are
defining it I know that but what I'm
saying is the labeling function would
take okay this function f would take row
names rose strings and it would turn
them into the label that you will show
for that row string right so if you look
at the entity store this will be at the
same level presumably as something which
says well I don't know why it needs to
even be if it's at that level it can be
done differently right so it says just
like you say label to use in displaying
this type okay so we could have write to
this level at this level here we'd be
saying how to you know we could have an
entity labels or we could have an entity
labeling function at that at that level
am I making sense at this level here but
we need to would need to repeat that for
property labels class labels property
classes that's correct
well still you can different ways
depending on how you view that will be
the level on which you define well keep
it sir hold on so this could say
entities arrow sum function you know
property classes arrow sum function etc
that make sense to people so that would
go at this level labeling functions
would go at this level
now you could go to a lower level but I
think this will be the most common case
is you won't want to define you know if
you want there is a problem with this
and it's that the one for entries needs
to be an entity function the other can
be pure functions why it's gonna be done
on the client side no it's going to be
done with clients oh no it's no no
that's better well then if it is an
entity function it can be done on the on
the server side if it is an identity
function it's on the client side
yeah well I mean whatever at least for
now for for databases we are disabling
this mechanism anyway because it doesn't
really make sense to make two different
queries one just for formatting and
database might get out of sync in the
meantime so well that's a different
issue you need to figure that out
no we've already so basically right now
for for entity stores they're back the
aunt is there is like one global special
property basically perper type that just
there is set to false and that tells you
that you should never try to do side
effects when I understand but here look
so can be either an entity function or a
generic function
we'll do different things because the
most common case is probably going to be
take the string and make some string
fluffing on it you know change the
undersold probably missed columns for it
to be an entity property which just
means use this property as label that's
correct
that's why because entity function hold
on I think the very most common thing
would be it would say entities arrow
inside there instead of F it will be
answered is arrow column name - I'm
saying no that's that's not that you see
this is why this is confusing because
there is a label for the entity type and
label for the sun'll I'm talking about
the I'm talking about the single entity
look at what I'm saying yeah I'm saying
this is labeling functions for the
top-level and it says the entity's
labeling function is F get what I'm
saying yeah but you cannot use the
string this rule means a constant
function
I think that's not right no I understand
that but that's a very common idiom that
we used these days
you don't want to have to say that
that's stupid to have to say you know
entity function of X as well oh yeah
that's Justin you can use entity
property there either way it's still
it's why not just use the define where
you can use of an entity property you
can use a string that's fine fine okay
so you're basically proposing a level of
indirection that by default points to
the label property but can be changed to
point to another property that's not
necessarily property it can be any
function that's why that's why I wrote
yes okay listen listen guys I need to
understand what is way we trying to
achieve in this meeting I'm gonna run
out of time in 15 minutes this is kind
of the last meeting that we need to have
in this series so what are we trying to
achieve in this particular meeting then
if we only have 15 minutes then then
maybe we should talk about this
relational database I'm sorry I I'm
sorry can we get an answer to that what
are we trying to achieve in this meeting
we
did not have a clear agenda for this
meeting what are we trying to achieve
here well you have several topics we
have also unlocked that being made I'm
sorry with you sorry well we have the
relational database that we didn't
finish last meeting and we have also a
design review that we make a mock-up for
today okay all right fine let's look at
the Billy stuff first okay I want to be
clear Andrea that's that I mean I don't
want to find out that whoops we didn't
get to this in this meeting so we have
specific things to do we have this
labeling stuff we just talked about okay
mostly that is not gonna make it for
this version but that's the plan for the
future right because that's thing number
one thing number two we're going to go
over this thing number three we're going
to talk about this relational database
wrapper thing number four if we have
time we'll talk about aggregation
function is that correct yes okay next
time please make sure we actually have
an agenda
don't just feed me back my notes from
last time
okay all right let's look at Billy's
mock-up here
you
that's quite nice so is this consistent
with our previous use of that weird
peeling banana icons yes because in the
end implicit entities can always be
represented as single entities of an
aggregator and see class okay I'm gonna
ask the question again what are we
planning to use this peeling banana icon
for
we're using it right now to represent
what
implicit entities all like the food ones
like the food ones
okay so it's all implicit entities yeah
and not all not even see classes all the
entities okay but so this is an entity
class and
I don't got Santino's are all entities
all of these aren't real so why are we
called so are you suggesting we
discontinue using this for the generic
entity class that was never used for a
generic entity class that which is what
we understand that I'm asking the
question is it the case that the current
implicit identities all correspond to
aggregated entity classes I think yes
then they can't be do we know is there a
translation from that arrow notation to
an aggregation entity class not as yeah
okay but if it isn't so where there is a
mechanism to not document it but it is
possible to convert every implicit
entity to an aggregated entity
class-based entity why don't you put a
function into the function repository
that does that yeah or properties and
relations in the documentation no no not
properties in relation to the
documentation of function in the
function repository okay because I meant
it right you can put it in properties
and relations as well but we want it as
a function in the function repository
I mean what we're trying to do is to get
rid of this thing where there's some
giant piece of code that gets put in the
documentation that's the only place to
find it
okay this one here I don't really know
why that means you get two types one is
red one is blue and then become as a
mongrel purple type I think it looks the
red it looks a little bit I don't know
um I'm not even sure you need two colors
there I think this arrow notation with
dots could be enough
well it's the only one that takes
actually two classes on me all right
fine
does the red scare you so to speak no
why would the red scare me I don't know
but it looks like an error
just make sure it's more purple than red
Billy
yep got it um I think that the idea we
were going for it's like primary colors
and people have a clear understanding of
how the weeks they're not gonna get that
they just gonna see two different colors
there was also another ether issue where
the mongrel entity was not mixed but it
was like just conjoined and kapner two
colors I think these look nice okay
did you Billy did you manage to make an
example with a dotted border yeah
can you post it or send it yes which
you're gonna do so the left one's the
original then think orange with the
dashes I think that's quite reasonable I
mean maybe the dashes could be the dots
were getting a little blurry but maybe
I was doing romance from people I think
that looks pretty reasonable it's
clearly something different and it seems
like there are many you know it has this
kind of metaphor of many
from people yeah that looks nice okay
another idea there is a there is one
thing that is nagging me a little bit
about it
and I I like it but to me a dotted
background means things can get in and
out and I wonder if there is a way to
make like change the background instead
of the of the border no I don't think so
unless you want to put you know unless
you want to have some weird very
precious dotted background which I guess
I was thinking of more like pinstripe
pinstriped no it won't be readable the
unless Billy unless the unless some idea
comes to you what's that you said in the
cloud for loading the back of the page
yeah but that's a very different thing
no but I was thinking like horizontally
pinstripe gives you an idea it's it's a
list of things like a you know like like
a notebook page it is light
what the heck does that have to do with
this I mean oh it's a class as opposed
to a single thing well I know that I
know that well
Billy do you think there's any hope of
something that goes on the background it
seems implausible to me yeah I mean yeah
maybe like a second border
now I don't think we want to sell
already we're already worrying about
height for these things yeah we already
don't like the fact that they have
additional height now I don't know
whether there's anything we can do to
make um I mean we could try something
where there's where it's solid at the
top and bottom and it's dotted at the
ends
does that help anybody I don't think
that really helps anything I think that
just makes it look like it's going to be
attached to something of the ends look
like that also they were like that frame
it was just be the expander yes that was
not successful um been on our live
stream is supporting the liking the
dashes um that's it's a good point it
gets more of a one-off instead of a
persistent entity class sort of
interesting I think we should go with
these dashes unless we unless we look at
them and decide that they're horrible
when when I deployed but that's what I
think we should go for all right let's
go back to the relational and database
wrapper okay just to summarize the
problem is that in general this stuff is
gonna forms to sort of graph of
relations to one another and the
question is whether you want to so the
current behavior of SQL can is to get
the whole connected component right if
that will be confusing so that I guess
that the two options are either you when
you inspect you message listen I'm
cutting some some edges here and then
you return just the thing okay
let's remember the context I mean so
relational database is the thing that
you apply to a database connection is
that right database reference or I mean
if it's in this case it's a file you can
just leave it as a string okay okay so
we're applying this and then this
relational database thing is gonna come
out with that wrapper that says what
tables are in the database is that
correct yes now sometimes you're in a
situation where there are I don't know
200 tables and this will take forever so
you just want to inspect a few I
understand that so how do you specify
which ones you want to inspect that's
the first argument
okay so okay so wait a minute so let's
just understand what this is okay
tables I want here right so there's
gonna be potentially a list of tables
there
it's that correct right yes okay and so
the issue now is whether it may be that
there is a reference from table one to
table three and you know exactly exactly
so you specified those tables but you
didn't specify the kind of the all or
something and this isn't the right way
to do it but you didn't specify the you
know finish the I don't know the
transitive closure the whatever it's
called you know the the the connected
component yeah
yes right so what we need and what we
need an analogy for is when do you and
we talked about last time you know
things like include definitions as an
analogy to this right
Nations tells you are you just storing
you're just saving this particular
similarly you saving this and it's
dependencies yeah yeah we could add an
option that says get get the whole
kinetic component but the question is
when you don't set that option I think
we're trying to do here so we want that
sum option here that says whether to get
the connected component or maybe how
much of the connected component to get
because it might be that you might say
you know there might be almost a max
items type thing that says you know you
might start getting the connected
component if it really is a thousand
tables you might not want to get all of
that that's more tricky but it's not so
much completed and that I mean in
general these this functionality should
allow you to you know say what kind of
columns do you want out you know if you
first thing you're saying is which
tables and now you're saying you wanna a
more fine-grained do you in fact more
fine-grained I don't think this is the
place for this we're doing here it's
getting the schemas yeah it doesn't
matter I mean you may be not but but I
mean in general yeah I mean and this is
probably more for entities for the
renaming is probably done at the level
so yeah tables and and column names okay
what would you call this this option
here
I mean related databases related or
would you follow relation or follow
foreign keys alright a related tables I
think notes worth well follow redirects
that's kind of interesting that's what
is that for that is what I
HTTP requests
I see that's the one time redirection
that's not okay so it's probably at this
level should be called follow foreign
keys
okay well let's understand what that
might mean so follow foreign keys I mean
really what it is is include tables
include what you get by following
foreign keys by resolving foreign keys
is that correct or following Lauren
please now following foreign keys ring
okay
set on a live stream is suggesting
neighboring tables arrow n or all it's
kind of interesting that meaning and
steps in the recursion yeah oh yeah
that's that's interesting um I I agree I
think that's interesting um but I don't
think that's quite the right name for it
but I think that concept is interesting
I mean the but I think that this the
fact that we can have an option like
this apart from the name is fairly
uncontroversial what is controversial on
the other hand is whether you should
keep the foreign keys when inspect and
there are two camps to this discussion I
think this should be kept because they
are part of that table even if they are
dangling references the others didn't
eat them what would you put in that are
you gonna drop you can you can just
filter them and I think that's crazy
we've got a nice symbolic language let's
put something in there that says missing
or some such other thing no it doesn't
it doesn't need to say missing the
problem is going to be that once I mean
once you version two we can write two
databases if you've done something like
this and you haven't followed all the
all the foreign keys you'll get into a
state that cannot be written you cannot
make those constraints all of it and so
I think Ricardo is saying let's see shoo
a message at at at real-time and drop
them and I say that's it so a message
should write and drop them
okay exfoliants to me so hold on I don't
know Esther on this okay so I'm gonna
try to the way I envision these objects
in the future is that when you when you
when you want to create a database this
contains all the information about the
database that you want to create I
imagine that you want to move the
database forward on backwards from one
state to the other right you want to add
the table add the column at the foreign
key you can imagine you have just an
object at the end and another object and
you say go to from from this state to
this state and oh man
the the problem I think is that
everything that is into the object needs
to be fully executed right and and
committed in an atomic transaction
otherwise you do a rollback now if you
do an inspection on a database and there
is a foreign key and you include this
foreign key even if there is no table
defined into this object the moment you
you are creating it then then basically
it will result in an error because it's
a hanging symbolic link and there is yes
and I think not either I'm gonna argue
against that I would have thought what
you want there is something that at the
client level in our language shows up as
some kind of missing thing and in the
case when you know if you brought in
something which has these hanging
foreign keys you should be able to if
you don't want them there if you want to
drop them just use delete missing or
some such other thing to get rid of them
and then you can go ahead and play and
write back the database to your heart's
content but I think it's wrong to not
have visibility I don't think I I don't
think that they should be replaced by
missing I think they should be there and
then what do they look like what is of
what is a foreign key look okay if only
that thing that's relational database
we're really running out of time it's an
association that's that contains
something like two two table from table
to column from column 2 like that
so now if you think that something went
wrong here so I don't you had something
wrong just two input form of of what of
this yeah okay at some point you should
see foreign key is there okay what do
they look like what on the same line
just on the Left foreign keys no okay
and it's silly that basically says from
this guy to this guy but so what I'm
saying is that you don't need the
missing there you can just check that to
T
police present in that set and any fit
is and you're trying to right then then
if I'm yeah exactly yes and then you can
say that gray out foreign key columns
don't remove them I agree it'd be crazy
there's no reason to remove them is my
oddly yes my only my only complain about
these is that the moment you are
creating an object with those like you
know reference like a constraint that
that reference to a table that is not
there we should fail we should not just
we have an option name we have to name
which is how much to recurse from
through the foreign key you know through
foreign keys right that reminds me of
web crawling what what does what is what
are the options to web crawl does
anybody know that that tells it how far
to recurse
maybe something that contains the word
depth
okay it's a little bit obscure if you
say foreign key depth that's really very
hard to parse option name how would they
check this thing with web crawl it's not
next I think it's in it's in it's in
documentation I mean it look at it and
uh still and I just want to mention for
completeness that I don't believe in
this depth approach and that my take on
this would be that if we want to save
some time not inspect everything then
inspection should become lazy
there is a simple insistent ice-cold
table depth sorry sorry that's
completely different thing table that
for something utterly different it's the
table form
sorry what Leonid you're saying that it
doesn't make sense to do yes I'm saying
that I don't believe in this I think
that right now the question was asked it
makes sense but when we add the writing
to the database then we should treat
entire database as a thing that exists
and so if we inspect part of it
we I would do it in a lazy in the lazy
way so that if we need if we need it for
writing for whatever we inspect whatever
subset of the tables that we really need
but we don't cut it on some arbitrary
condition that you go only that far it
just doesn't make sense for me okay well
okay we need a name for this particular
option so in web chrome map there as Mac
max depth and max items
yeah max depth is totally obscure look
for a full of foreign keys it's probably
given that we've actually calling these
things foreign keys right there in the
structure that probably is and I guess
since everybody in the database will
call some foreign keys maybe that's what
we do and if it turns out we can later
on have an actual number then so be it
but for the time I think you either want
yes or no you don't want you don't want
partial like do it twice and then stop
and think hold on is it follow foreign
keys or pull in the foreign keys I mean
it's not really follow it it's whether
those foreign key pieces are include you
know include followed foreign keys is
kind of the know you're including the
tables you're including tables that are
pointed to by foreign keys so I mean it
would be something like include foreign
key tables although it isn't really
tables at our level it's uh it's a life
would be more like foreign key types no
no
the tables or something like that
because related tables yeah I think it's
the best so far
and this should still be called tables
because they were not met we haven't
made them into types yet maybe just
including related okay why include
related now I like include related
tables oh yeah what Carl on our live
stream is commenting that weren't we
shouldn't use foreign keys in the name
because in the future we might have
graph databases and entity stores
yeah but graph databases will will have
a different symbol not relational
database so to reuse the option look I
think include related tables is a
reasonable thing to say
okay I agree okay and I have to go
unfortunately so one last question okay
we decided to give the the foreign key
but I still think that maybe maybe it's
still better to send a message in case
you are saying you know this guy 2 vols
and then the result there is a relation
you are not following we should say
message look you are not following this
relation you would like to say
reasonable foreign key is a present
relation is not being followed
that sounds highly reasonable to me yeah
okay okay I'm not very happy with this
message thing because you're you you you
ask something very precisely you set an
option you okay explicitly set the
option okay so maybe the compromise is
if the option is set to false then you
don't issue a message right but if
exactly matter yes right what the heck
does automatic do it means false but
true messages I don't know that seems a
little weird but that's the only way I
mean the option cannot be unset really
either set it I mean if the default is
false then putting false explicit you
should have this extra I don't know
whether we should have a I don't think
it's I look I just don't know and
database practice whether
[Music]
but I mean I think that ethically we are
doing this inspection and searching for
you know what part of the database they
need to use it's an useful thing you can
always ignore it on our live stream
started suggesting include foreign key
table that is nice to know that
selectively and the way it says you know
table see maybe you should considering I
think we should have the message at the
beginning we can always you know we can
always decide we don't need the message
um I think that the right place for the
message is right that's reading greedy
it doesn't let's put the message in for
now okay let's put the message in for
now and we can take it out if we think
it's stupid if we get too annoyed by
seeing it will take it out I have to run
hopefully we this is the end of this
series of meetings to review
documentation did our song next time
you've got to be much better organized
than this meeting okay I really hope we
don't have to spend much more time on
this okay I got a run right now um
thanks to all see ya bye